we know who did it when they did it and
how they did it he's Ryan O'Reily this
Center for the st. Louis Blues won the
Conn Smythe Award the MVP of the Stanley
Cup playoffs Congrats Ryan how are you
feeling are you roughed up a little bit
[Music]
same time we've been having a blast and
still can't believe that we just want to
stand the cup B beers two hours of sleep
ratio would be what is the party over
oh definitely not it's kind of just
keeps going every day there's something
doing
we're so excited though you know we
worked so hard for it and such a great
group of guys we're enjoying we're
enjoying being chance take me back to
when you found out that you had been
traded this is what your agent told me
July first your agent calls you and says
you were traded and you asked where and
he said your acquisition and with the
current team you're going to you're
gonna win the Stanley Cup you remember
that conversation I do pretty amazing
and knowing a few guys on the team I'm
playing a lot international stuff with
and then kind of look and look at the
roster after it was just like yeah it's
definitely possible but I can't believe
the road that and like the rollercoaster
of a ride it was to to win a cup but I
remember that phone call and I think it
was yeah there couldn't be a better team
to go to to have a chance and look at us
now
but I also you know even in Game seven I
mean Boston threw everything at you and
you guys had a slow start but you still
lead one-nothing
and they had so many shots on goal and
then
they didn't score I thought oh my gosh
that's got to be devastating to Boston
they've given you everything they got
they have nothing to show for it and
then you guys get that second goal and
then I thought you know what it's
probably over did you get that feeling
at all yeah it was kind of obviously
wasn't a great start by us but it was
unbelievable again he stopped humbling
[Music]
we kind of get to see them come back and
then we just know we're gonna frustrate
I wrote a lot of her best I did you know
what you know what Ryan hold on for a
second I think you're going through a
bad sell section there well see if we
can get that fixed here or the bar that
they're in doesn't it's not a concrete
around I could hear noises there and
then I think it was just you know maybe
somebody giving him directions there one
of the great things about the Stanley
Cup is the day after you could live
vicariously through people who are at
bars at 11:00 a.m. on a Thursday like
there's some bar called like OBEs or
something and like the Blues just showed
up and they all just pile in 20 dudes
Ryan is back with us there so Ryan I'm
not sure where we left off but it was
surviving that barrage of shots in the
first period there with Game seven and
Ryan II there tell Ryan Thank You Todd
because I think that we got a bad bad
connection there so tell him thank you
we appreciate that and tell him
congratulations as well wonderful story
there yeah yeah I'm gonna put fritzy in
the cone of silence here's he talks to
to Ryan O'Reily
yes Paulie I heard the cone behind me
yeah just so much shame I know
shame I it never fails
Fritzie always says it was good
connection when I was talking to him
something happens when he puts him on
hold and then I pick him up and then
it's not a good connection yes Paul next
time the blues when the cup will have
another world it's gonna happen again
sorry about that horse she I mean that's
that's a terrible way to end a Friday
here I don't know what to do about those
situations and I never will as long as
this is the technibond connection
thought it out okay yeah but don't don't
go into the weekend thinking about that
yeah it's just it's frustrating make the
effort to track some again and get them
on and then you know the last piece of
the puzzle is just effective sound good
what you would think would be the
easiest part of the yes process shame
shame shame kind of ruin the week no oh
no there's no reason to continue it
Charles Barkley come on Kawhi Leonard
came on before the end of the show that
whatever edie man man Kyle Lowry
maybe if we had collide just laughing I
mean I'd be fine with Kawhi laughing
that'd be good for more Dan Patrick show
tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV streamed for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]